buddy i'm appa danskran from gopher i
worked
as a data scientist i've been working
there now
a little bit over two years and well
i've been doing quite many
different uh projects anything from
basic data analytics to more advanced
like machine learning methods to
predict electricity consumption
and and so on also i've been working
with sat puts on
this natural language processing
projects and
yeah i would say natural language
processing or nlp insult
has been my special interest a few years
now
and especially this very latest uh
transformer based models
which are like every new every
new models and papers are coming up
almost every week or month and so it's
quite interesting
field to be working with and yeah
that's why i'm going to present for you
today about serosa text classification
without cpt-3
yes you don't need tpc3 for every single
thing in the world you can manage
without it
quite nicely and yeah
i will show you first the accent of my
presentation so i have
three points at first i will give you a
brief introduction to that zero text
classification
and try to explain what does it mean and
how does it work
and then next i will go briefly
through through some like pros and cons
of trafford text classification compress
to
a more let's say traditional way of
fine-tuning your
your own nlp classifier
and lastly if we still have time i will
show you some quick live demos of zero
text classification
and yeah if you have questions please
just write them down
and i will answer them later at the end
of the presentation
all right so yeah
at first i could um clarify a couple of
topics in the context of context of my
presentation
so when i'm talking about kerosene i'm
meaning like okay
uh learning might be a familiar topic
for you from some other
data science tasks like from computer
vision
or somewhere but in in the context of
this presentation and
nlp by sarasota i'm i'm meaning that
we are trying to get some uh nlp model
to do something else it wasn't actually
explicitly trained for originally so
that's the
terrorist part and when i'm talking
about nlp models i'm
referring to the transformer based
language models for example google's
bird or
gpd3 or import or whatever we have so
many
different models nowadays so
i'm talking about those latest models
and yeah and then
if you are working especially in the
business side
for example i'm working with some like
companies and they have some problem
okay we want to classify some text
but there usually are some problems with
the data
they might they might not even have any
data
which you could use to train your
supervas
text classifier or if they have data
it's usually not
labeled so you need to use a lot of time
and resources to label the data
so there are these common problems with
access to good enough quality labeled
data sets
usually what you need to train your own
own text classifier in the traditional
so-called traditional way
so that that's like interesting
challenge
that could be actually use some other
nlp models
trained for some other common tasks
already available
to do the text classification in my
specific text classification problem or
task
so that's the total thought
classification could we get some
some an nlp model to do the
classification for us
even though we don't have data to train
our own classifier
uh thought answer yes we can
um the headline is little it's already
telling
a little secret about it how it's going
how it's going to happen but
at first i'm going to expl uh give you a
brief introduction to nle
task which we are going to use to do
that
text classification so
nle is a third version of
natural language inference and natural
language importance is
a one of the most common nlp tasks or
problems
especially in the research side so
because it's a common task and we have a
lot of like uh
benchmark benchmark datasets for that
task and so on so we have
a lot of different available good
quality
labeled data sets both nle
problem and also we have a lot of
already pre-trained or fine-tuned
nle nlp models
available for free to use so
we could use that those resources
available
to do that zero subtext classification
and if you are not familiar with the nle
task
i'm trying to give you a short
introduction how what does it actually
mean or what
what we are going to do with analysis or
the nle
is actually a task of determining
whether
some hypothesis is true false
or undetermined given some premise
so basically generally morale is trying
to
it's like hypothesis is testing task or
model
so the model is trying to like predict
whether
whether a hypothesis entails a premise
or does it
contradict with the premise or is it
like neutral
to the premise
in in practice this is a sequence per
classification task so
we have hypothesis and we have a premise
two different test
texts and those both are fed together
through the model
and the model tries to predict one glass
of
entailment contradiction only pro
and here i have two examples
so if we have a premise of like
a group of data scientists are listening
presentation about nlp
like we are right now doing
and then we have a hypothesis okay some
people are playing football
um human could say that hypothesis is
false
it's it contradicts the premise and so
the model should also predict
uh the contrary contradiction class
but if we have the same premise again
but we
change the hypothesis into some people
are participating in technology
presentation
uh the morale should predict a class of
entailment so it's actually true the
hypothesis
should be true so
this is like how the nle task
works and how those nle models are
working
so it's basically a hypothesis testing
testing kind of
task
yeah next slide i will
try to explain how can we now
turn the um normal
text classification task into nle task
so we can
use those available nle models to
do the zero subtext classification so
this idea of using analytics for
zero subtext classification was
originally proposed by yin and
al um at the last slide i have
some links for you to read if you want
later on
for the paper and some blog posts so
the idea what the unit all proposed was
that okay
we could uh use the premise
no sorry we could use the text we want
to classify
as the premise and then we might have
some
candidate labels what the text might be
about
and we will use those labels as a
hypothesis
and how we are going to do that is that
we
uh we we need to formulate those
candidate labels into some kind of
hypothesis format
so usually there are many different ways
you can do that and some ways works
better for some
specific text classification problems
and some for some orders but
some like common general way is
in this uh second sub
bullet here um so we can formulate the
hypothesis as his text is about some
some candidate label
and so so the analy model
then tries to trust to predict whether
this hypothesis is true false or neutral
and if the analyte model predicts the
class of true
so the end element class we will assume
that okay
it's true and this this candidate label
is true
so the text is about that label
um one one more point about the
hypothesis format so as you can see the
format
this text is about something it mimics
how humans would do the
text classification so we actually like
mimicking how humans would do that
classification so
for example um
if i'm reading some news article and
then some
some person comes and asks ask from me
okay hey
can you tell me what what is the topic
of that
news article and then in my mind i i
would like make this hypothesis okay i
think this text is about politics
so we are actually trying to mimic that
with that
human way of classifying with the nle
models
um yeah um i have little
example here so again we have the same
premise as
as previously a group of data scientists
are listening presentation about nlp
and our task is to classify whether this
text is about technology or not
so we can formulate uh the hypothesis as
his text is about technology and then
the
nla morale could predict the class of
entailment through
so this text is about technology
but that was only like
one class but what if we have a multiple
candidate labels for example for the
news articles we could have many many
different possible
news news topics so how can we classify
that
with the analytic model and we can do it
by feeding every single candidate label
separately through the model and then at
the end we
take the entailment dimension of the
output
take the logics and then we like do the
soft max over that
so we can get scores for all labels and
see which which label gets the highest
highest probability so here again
i have a real-life example of of
again the same same premise a group of
data scientists are listening
presentation about nlp
and then we have some candidate labels
okay this
text could be about technology it could
be about
sports or would it be about politics or
could it be about
economy and then
we will feed those candidate labels
through the model and get the
attend to the softmax and get the scores
for every
label together and here it's it
it's a real example what i have those
scores here i
i did it previously and so the
technology gets like 995
probability and economy sports and
politics are like almost
zero so that that seems to be working
quite well and yeah that's the basic
idea how the
uh how can we use nle models to do
zero sort of text classification that's
kind of i think it's kind of a nice idea
how can we like mimic
the human way of classifying text with
these
neural networks and nlp models
um yeah then
finally some pros and cons comparing to
the more let's say traditional way of
fine-tuning your own supervised
classifier
and by i i'm by that i mean
with this latest transformer based and
the bimulus you usually
take some large pre-trained language
model
and then you have let's say some much
smaller
labeled data set for some classification
tasks and
then you like fine-tuned the pre-trained
model for that
classification task so that's the let's
say traditional way
of using this latest state-of-the-art
analgemolis to do the classification
so if we compare that to the therapeutic
way
uh of course the big pro of zero zot
classification
is that you actually don't need any
labeled data sets
for training your own classifier and
you don't need to use resources for
training
classifier so you can
especially for let's say um proof of
concept project
if you want to just like your id okay
maybe in this problem i could
need the classification part of some
bigger bigger system
i could just quickly try out okay
uh does it work or not in my case and i
i just
i can just take an ali model
and try to try the terrorist
classification
and see does it work or not and if it if
it
if it gives me a good good examples then
i would
maybe use some resources to actually get
the label to dataset and train my
better model for that so it's it's quite
enough
quite nice because you can immediately
immediately uh
straight away get get three uh results
with danielle
morris and yeah but with the supervised
classification you need to always like
train your specific classifier
and you need to have good enough labeled
data set and
yeah so it you need more resources for
that
and another another big pro
pro of serotonin text classification is
that you can actually use the same anal
for multiple different domains and
labels
if that model has been originally
trained with a
good quality data set which has like
text examples from different domains and
labels and so on
so you can use it for example to
classify news articles or
classified sentiment of some text or
almost almost
anything and but with supervised
methods you can only predict classes
introduced
introduced in the training data set so
it's more limited in that sense
but then negative thing about
zero subtext classification is that um
it's if you are going to use that model
moral
inner production so we we call it
inference so
the inference speed it's usually
slower or much slower than the
supervised
classifier especially if you have many
many candidate labels because you need
with the terrorist models you need to
always
feed through each and every candidate
label
separately through the model so it takes
more time to get
get the end result with the serious
models
but with supervised classifier you can
only fit through the texture
text to be classified once and you will
get
the results straight away so the
influence speed
should be much weaker
um also another negative
thing about the terrorist classification
is that
of course you you cannot expect as as
good as
uh as good accuracy as with uh
supervised methods
because the well the
analyst wasn't trained with your your
very specific data so of course you
cannot expect as
as good accuracy as with the supervised
methods but in my
i've been um testing those zeros of
mothers
a little bit and i think for some common
text classification uh task
you can actually get quite quite nice
and maybe good enough results with that
serotonin method sorry
so it still has a lot of
different like use cases
and yeah one one final
negative thing about the terror stock
method is that um
each candidate label you may have need
to be able to
be formulated as a natural line is
hypothesis so
again the human way to classify text
so for example if you have some business
case that you need to classify
this text into number one and this text
in the number two
and another text in the number three you
cannot do that
with the result way because
if you formulate the hypothesis again
in the format of this text is about
something
and then you have candidate labels of
numbers
and you have now for example hypothesis
this text is about one and the text
and the text you want to classify is is
something
business related stuff so it cannot
actually like
know that well is it about one not
number one or no
or not so those labels you
need to be formulated as a natural
language
hypothesis so that that might be a
limiting thing in some cases
but yeah i think we still have time for
demos
so i could now switch on to the
demo demo section
um yeah
wait a minute i'm drawing okay yeah
so yeah uh you should now see my collab
google goal up
you may be familiar with the call up so
it's basically
a jupiter notebook in the cloud offered
by google and you can get
gpus for free but actually i'm now using
all the
cpus at the go up but yeah um
if you have been working with nlp stuff
you
and especially with this latest
transformer based models
you may be familiar with the hacking
phase and hacking phase transformers so
i'm using that library here and it's
really
really nice library for many nlp
transformers nlp tasks and again
i also have this another library from
hacking phase called datasets
which you can use to load many many
different datasets but actually in this
this demo i'm not using that but i
just quick hint you you can use that
this to get
to load many many many common datasets
for training your own own moths or
testing your own models if you want
after that we just like import the
pipelines from
transformers so transformers they if you
want to for example
demo some stuff they offer these quick
pipelines for
doing the common stuff quickly without
coding too much by yourself but if you
want to maybe go into production you
may want to do some other stuff by
yourself
so then we just load uh uh this teresa
classif
classifier model with the pipeline so we
at the serous
classification here we want to load that
kind of pipeline
and then we are defining a model
and now i'm using this modal code
part plus mnm
so this is actually this part model is
from facebook
and it's it's a large variant of that
and if
that model has been fine-tuned for this
nle
task so that's right here we have this
nle part in at the end
but you can also here's a link for the
hard investment
repository so you can see some other
other available fine-tuned nla mulas
from
from there for the zero subtext
classification problem
and yeah then i just copied uh
maybe was it last week also i went to
the
euler this finnish national broadcasting
company
to last news website and i search for
english english news folder and i'll
just copy it
copy it few text for demo purposes here
so this
first text is a news article about
i don't know if you can see but it's
about some football finnish football
stuff so it should be about sports news
and then we have the second text with
which is about
some finnish politics about like this
prime minister
and her her party stuff so it's like
politics news
and then i added some candidate labels
into the list so we have sports economic
politics and culture
so we could try to classify those two
news articles into one of those
possible candidate labels
and then we just uh with this uh
hockeyface pipeline we only give that
text we want to classify
and then the candidate labels and then
we can formulate some kind of hypotheses
and here i'm just using this what common
for formula of this text is about and
then we add the
candidate label at the end so if we now
run it let's see if it works or
do we get some demo effects it might
take few seconds to load
because yeah actually the news article
is quite long article and we have
four different candidate labels so as as
i said the
uh classification is bit slower than the
more traditional supervised
classification methods
especially with the tpus
when we are using these a lot
transformers
those are quite slow with gpus usually
um
so here we get the results and as we can
see uh
uh we have sports as a number one
label and it has the probability of
57 percentage so we could say
the zeros of classifier was able to
classify it correctly
because it was about some finnish
portable stuff
then if we do the second
classification so now we have the
article about some
finnish politics stuff so let's see do
we get the politics as a number one
class
and yes we do again we have
the politics as a number one
clasp and again the score is about like
58
so not not so high but still uh
quite a bit higher than the other other
levels we
had in the candidate label list so i
think the model was again
able able to classify the text
what quite nice but then um
my mouse is lagging a little bit but
okay now it should work
my last demo part is that okay we can
actually you
as as i said in the pros of zero
software we can actually use the same
nle model for different domains and
different
classification tasks and with different
labels so now
those first two examples were like
uh topic topic classifications but now
we switch to
sentiment analysis of sentiment
classification so
he has just typed this uh so-called
movie review
about the movie tennis and it says that
okay the
movie was really great but maybe the
maybe it was pretty long so some
negative
negativity at the end of the text and i
gave it a
candidate labels of positive and
negative
and again the same hypothesis this text
is about something
and now i just before
click the run button and we can see the
results of
positive being 63 and negative
36 so we could say okay the same analym
also works for sentiment classification
at least with this
quick demo but um
one last part of my demo i could
show you that actually with these nla
models or this terrorist way of
classifying with the analymers
you it might be beneficial to actually
um a little bit like try out different
kind of hypothesis templates
so we can um one common way of maybe
actually introducing the paper i
mentioned earlier
in the paper they they used a little bit
different
hypothesis template for sentiment
classification
and it was actually like uh
in the format of this text x
process now we have that so
now it's more like human way again we
are having this
template that this text expresses
expresses some kind of
emotion or sentiment so now if
when we run it again with that
hypothesis template
we can see that okay the positive got a
little bit higher scored and
previously so the model is maybe more
confident that okay
it's actually positive movie review
which in in my mind it's it still is
positive
moving review so yeah
you you may need to like try out
different different
hypothesis templates to get better
results with the therapeutics
classification
and in that sense it's little bit
resembles the
cpt3 hype that you need to like
be like prompt engineer and do some
prompt engineering
so now we are doing hypothesis
engineering we try to like
get get the best results with some
specific hypothesis template at your
specific text classification problem
yeah that was my presentation i'll
just show the last slide so here you can
see
the link to the paper i can actually
maybe add those links to that
set too so you can open them better but
yeah link to the paper and also a link
to
one blog post about service of text
classification
and yeah you can contact me at linkedin
or now or send me email at
my first name last name at go4.com
and yeah thank you for inviting me to
speak and if you have any questions i'm
now free to ask thanks apple thank you
very much
uh that was really interesting and very
insightful and
about the last uh classification example
about tenet
it's also hard for humans too so
yeah i know uh yeah
so i have few questions from the
participants
one from uh bialy uh
so uh uh yeah uh if
well i read it out so if i understand
correctly uh we can only use the
pipeline if the transformer
model has already been fine to to
perform this task
uh yeah so i would love to try
zero shot classification on swedish test
text
do you think maybe i can fine tune a
swedish perch
on this classification task please
correct me if i'm wrong
and thank you yeah that's good that's
good question uh
yeah so the model i used in the demo
it was already fine-tuned for the nle
stuff
uh nla task and it was fine-tuned with
english
data set and the pre-trained
language model facebook's bot
it was also english model so it only
supports english
text but actually if you go to the
hacking phase model repo
sortery you can already find some
multilingual
models fine-tuned for the nle task so
you can use those models
to do multi-lingual zeros of text
classification and
there are also more for example the
also from facebook model called xlm
roberta or xlmr for sword
that's the multi-lingual moral it
supports like 100 different languages
swedish include i'm i'm quite confident
because finnish is also supported by
that model
so swedish swedish should be supported
too
and those mothers have already have been
fine-tuned for the
nla that too so you can use that
to classify some swedish texts
but you can also try out your fine
tuning your own
nle classifier and then use that for the
terror sort classified classic
classification and i have been also
doing that
or experimenting with that um i i don't
have any finis
or speed i don't know if there are
swedish nle
data sets available but if they are you
can actually
um take the pre-trained swedish
birth model and fine-tune that for the
nle problem with the
sweet swedish nla data set but i don't
know if there are available
swedish analytics but anyway you can try
out that
also by yourself if you want i've been
trying that and it's quite easy
if you just have the available nle data
[Music]
uh well uh there is one no uh
yeah that is a good question and uh uh
well i have also one question of my own
uh maybe a little bit related to this
uh when i in your demo i saw that uh
you chose uh to uh implement uh like
bart if i bought an ali if i saw it
correctly
uh is that any is that a preference or
uh
uh like why did you choose exactly that
one over uh for example bear too
or was it just for the demo
uh yeah it was just for the demo
because um um how could i expect
shortly well uh that bad model has been
like
favored morale for like
classification by hacking face people so
that's why i use it
and if you just those um
nle models for serious text
classification problem in the hog in
phase
repository you can see there are maybe
less than 10 ml available
already so not so many but i i'm not
sure if they had any
bad model or alternative brands built
but i think they have bought and the
xlmr which is the multilingual version
but
actually you could use uh there are many
many many many nlemors in the hockey
phase repository but the hacking phase
teresa classification pipeline requires
some
modifications to the that to that
model's
config file and so that's why you cannot
use
those um other nle models which i'm sure
there are some analysts trained with
or fine-tuned with
but they have a little bit different
config file so you need to modify that
before you
you can load it with the pipeline so
that's why you cannot
uh out of the box use those but it's
quite easy
modification you just need to like
change
few few lines uh i can tell you more
about it later if you want
yeah thanks thanks uh i have another
question
from radin uh are there any issues
with more exotic languages such as
finnish
uh for example being less accurate in
predictions comparing to
english uh yeah and there is a
question so he's asking i think
uh it goes same as the first question uh
like uh is asking about the accuracy of
finnish compared to english
yeah i would say it's um
you cannot maybe expect as good as good
accuracy as with english or more more
common languages it's it's common
problem with nlp stuff because we don't
have so many
data sets and models for finnish or more
more
not not so common languages um
but with the multi-lingual morality xlmr
which i mentioned earlier you can
actually quit quite
nice i think at least for some common
common
classification problems quite nice
results also in finnish texts
i actually i've been myself trying to
fine-tune my own multi-lingual analytic
model for terrorist
tasks um but the problem is that you
you don't have in nle data sets in
finnish at least not yet
but you have like some multilingual nle
models which have
uh sorry data sets which include like
maybe 10 different
languages but not not finnish but if you
have the use the multi-lingual for
example the xlmr
pre-trend model as a as the base model
which
already supports 100 different languages
and has been trained with finished data
but if you take that and find doing that
with your own more specific nle data
sets containing let's say 10 different
languages but not finished
the fun part is that actually the model
still supports finish but maybe not
not as good as if you would have
had some finished finish nla examples
in the dataset but yeah you can try it
out it can work
and i think it works in some cases i
think
if i remember correctly i'd write with
one of my own like
finnish uh news topic uh
classification test sets and
i think with like um training the
traditional supervised classifier with
that
and using that test test set i was able
to get like let's say over 90
90 accuracy and with training the
multi-link well
there wasn't an le classifier i was able
to get maybe
some some thing like 75 or
around that level of accuracy so not as
high as that traditional way but still
still like
quite nice
[Music]
thanks thanks thank you very much so i
guess uh
that's it uh yeah no more questions for
you
and uh no problem thank you thank you
again